you are a masculine man just you reek of
pheromones yeah you really do
yeah I'm kind of feeling the same from
you right but there is a I have to tell
you I don't know if I know it's a bit of
a stereotype but but I always think of
like Scottish people from Scotland as
being and the men is being very manly
and then you personify that you know and
it's not just because I've watched three
hundred like nine times and I always oil
myself beforehand my business not yours
now what you could stop sending me those
photos you like am I wrong or is it just
the perception is that a man in in and I
don't know if it goes back to like you
know James the first James Bond why am i
blanking Sean Connery a Braveheart
Braveheart was back a couple of thousand
years before the yeah but he does
personify you do too it's this like I
just feel like you could get up in the
morning and eat a rock if you had to and
sometimes you do yeah yeah I I have done
yeah or smoked one yeah
people love celebrity okay there's
nothing that makes a publicist happier
just work in crack cocaine in the
dressing room so here's my question is
it just a stereo why do we have that
impression
no because there is a lot of that in
Scotland I mean there's you know Sean
Connery to me personifies that kind of
image but and I think it does come
historically from there a very warring
nation yes and there's a they're
fighters yeah yeah
so even amongst that was a lawyer even
amongst lawyers doctors whatever is
there still ready to rumble yeah no and
there's like and there's just this it's
the way we speak as well we speak with
our throat and our tongue you know and
you kind of throw things out and you
speak with a lot of passion and you
usually hey you know what pop like this
you know so it but it's funny because I
have that big energy which i think is a
is a very Scottish thing but for me I
had to in some ways get rid of all that
in America guy had to like learn to not
use the back of the tongue so much and
the throat so much and and and also take
all that big energy and sucker right and
that's too bad because we look at me I
speak I don't not only do I not speak
from the back of my throat I speak from
the front part of my lips
you know there's no you shouldn't change
and become more like us we need to
become more like you guys I think that's
a good point but right now when you're
making movies and you're playing
American and III kind of have to do that
a bit but in the long run that is my
ploy to make America Scotland yeah looks
like it's not very big green line you'll
come with me by the way you know what's
really funny is I just wrapped a movie
last week called Greenland your kid I
did so I was in Greenland last week yes
but what do you think that movies coming
out like in nine months a year yeah nine
months when it comes out the new title
will be Greenland USA because it's
actually about us trying to get to these
bunkers that world nuclear bunkers that
we now need because there is this kind
of planetary disaster and but were you
were talking about that I thought that
would be all we did we arrived in
Greenland and all you see is Trump
bunkers you mean a good way hey what
we're on the subject of Scotland kilts I
went to a wedding once and I was
required to wear a kilt and I loved it I
bet I thought it was fantastic I didn't
know how I was gonna feel about it have
you had a lot of experience with yeah
we're born and kills with the worst
diapers you know they just like but no I
I born
I've not worn a kill as much as you
would as much as you would think but I
have I wore a kilt
at my brother's wedding in my sister's
wedding and me and I loved it both times
but they were both disasters because at
my sister's wedding I had to do the
first readings I was on the altar it was
a Catholic wedding there's like 400
people in the congregation and I'm and
I'm sitting looking at my mom's in the
front row and she's looking up at me and
I'm and I'm looking down every my mom is
like this and I think she's telling me
it's a break so she's saying please
please PLEASE right you should be doing
so I'm sitting there and I go like this
and I put my hat and just and I looked
at my leg and right kill a spread white
of my leg but it's feasting the whole
congregation so I slowly you know like
across there is no it's it is a
tradition there's no wearing of
underwear right
there's no no that's oh yeah she no we
don't wear underwear under a kilt yeah
you're not supposed to I definitely that
date was not wearing underwear I think
when I went to my friend's wedding I was
wearing seven pairs of underwear I was
so afraid I was so petrified